bonjour fléchissement bonjour monsieur
car oui j'ai beau joual havane
population de bellefontaine maire de
bellefontaine justement depuis 2008 mais
votre concurrent dans ce scrutin ne se
gêne pas pour dire que vous étiez déjà
aux affaires municipales alors pas en
tant que maire mais d'une manière ou
d'une autre avec ernest renard qui avait
lui même précédé maxence de luge qui a
eu qui a fait deux mandats
bref il deale résume ainsi que ça fait
40 ans que vous occupez plus ou moins
une activité une fonction au sein de la
municipalité de bellefontaine alors à
votre tour dites-nous phoenix 6 mais
pourquoi vous avez décidé de tenter de
briguer un mandat supplémentaire vous ne
voulez pas raccrocher ou en tout cas pas
encore pas maintenant non j'ai donné 45
ans de ma vie à ma population à
bellefontaine
il faut savoir qu'avant avant d'être
maire avant d'être dans la vie
municipale
j'ai été au coeur même de la vie
footballistiques
j'ai été entraîné au joueur de l'équipe
à 22 ans ce qui est étonnant pour
beaucoup de monde et j'ai pu ramener le
club en division d'honneur et restera
est venu me chercher en me disant qu'ils
allaient faire de moi son dauphin
j'ai accepté d'être sur la liste bao que
moi je n'avais organiser ma vie en
fonction de père de mère la conquête et
depuis vous n'avez pas quitté et vous
voulez encore poursuivre oui parce que
j'ai signé un contrat moral avec ma
population j'ai mis l'humain au coeur
même de la politique
faut vous dire que quand je suis arrivé
à la mairie j'ai embauché 80 personnes
il y avait une douzaine d'enfants de
bellefontaine qui souhaitait continuer
leurs études par le biais de
l'alternance
ils sont venus me voir j'ai pu leur
trouver un patron ils ont été reçus à
aller aux examens aujourd'hui les douze
travail dans toutes les structures où
j'ai siégé j'ai pu mettre au moins au
moins l'enfant de bellefontaine danse et
vous présenter ce mandat peut-être même
cette mission de maire comme une espèce
de sacerdoce quasiment c'est une
sacerdoce monsieur
car oui je pense qu'à un moment pdc sur
la gonave martiniquais aimé césaire est
venu me voir le 3 avril 2008 quand j'ai
été élu et il m'a tenu ces propos
vous savez monsieur le maire est une
sacerdoce un vous aurez beaucoup plus de
beaucoup plus de deux défaites que de
joie et ma foi ces chercheurs constatent
alors un regard sur les six dernières
années un donc sur votre mandature
l'acquis qui s'achève une mandature qui
a été marquée par un épisode assez
malheureux alors je sais pas comment on
peut dire est ce que c'est un
contentieux un litige administratif et
politique avec une policière municipale
qui qui a même entamé une grève de la
faim dans les locaux mêmes de la mairie
de bellefontaine j'aimerais bien
comprendre il ne pourra pas être trop
long là dessus j'aimerais bien vois pas
de voile à une personne qui est venue à
mon bureau que je ne le connaissait ni
d'eve ni d'adam me disant qu'elle avait
faim qu'elle avait été ouais je suis un
con qu une bénifontaine n est pas de
bellefontaine et je lui ai donné la mer
quelque sorte
voyez là suffisent de malheureux donc
quelqu'un vous dit ben qu'est la fin
vous essayez de lui donner mais c'est ce
que j'ai fait et puis finalement elle
s'est retournée combine allemand est ce
que vous estimez ne peut pas on peut pas
dire si oui ou non elle a été malhonnête
c'est le mot bon on va pas on va pas
refaire
mise à part que c'est que ça a l'air de
vous avoir beaucoup marqué c'est
vous avez dernière mandature j'ai
quarante deux ans de vie politique et
c'est la chose qui m'a le plus marqué
dans ma vie politique
ah ouais tout de même tout de même alors
mise à part ça qu'est ce qui a
caractérisé ces six dernières années à
bellefontaine de quoi vous êtes le plus
fier qu'est ce qui vous vient
immédiatement à l'esprit
mais il ya que des ouï oui là que vous
avez réalisés au cours des six dernières
années mais je suis en train de réaliser
pour les marins pêcheurs de
bellefontaine des étals de vente de
poissons et c'est ma fierté tant elle
était temps quand même belle fontaine
c'est oui c'est un coût d'une dépêché
cinq semaines le bras d'or du poisson
tout ça donc vous mettez ça j'aimais ça
passe tout seul pas tout seul avec
l'aide de la cité m alors j'ai eu une
aide de la ctm et une led candidats à
l'état mais c'est une opération qui a
déjà débuté et qui dans quelques dans
quelques mois d'ici trois quatre mois
les marins pêcheurs sont heureux de se
retrouver dans trois écoles ne sait pas
encore tout à fait terminé cette annonce
est en train de moi je vous parler de
quelque chose de réaliser deux dernières
années j'ai réalisé la maison des
associations j'ai réussi réalisé c'est
vous le service technique de la mairie
de bellefontaine il y à auvernier au
quartier verrier un endroit où les
jeunes peuvent s'amuser avec bien sûr
une salle je dirais une salle de
réception avec intel intégré en
contrebas où les jeunes et dimanche
dernier j'étais au verrier avec pour le
carnaval
j'ai pu apprécier le nombre d'enfants
qui étaient sur ce qu'est ce que vous
proposez de fort pour les six prochaines
années
c'est quoi votre projet phare à l'avant
projet phare il est là
mais j'étais problème avec la dr j'ai
des problèmes avec la dl parce que je
l'aménagement l'aménagement du front de
mer de bellefontaine
c'est ça mon dossier phare pour 15
millions d'euros
c'est ce qui va occuper la prochaine
mandature au canada si vous être élu
monsieur k oui je remercie philippe six
mains d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans sa aux gars des spéciales municipal
réalisé par adele qui kelly et ma patte
d'oie
[Musique]